hi I'm Eric Boston a ventures in game
has now cleared the spoiler window and
given the massive turnout at Tony
Stark's funeral plus the thousands of
people working on Spider Man far from
home with its multiple Iron Man in
memoriam Banksy's it's pretty miraculous
that end games ending was kept so under
wraps a big reason for that secrecy was
the decision by the Russo brothers to
write and shoot several alternate
endings who deliberately misdirect the
cast and crew so that when Mark Ruffalo
says everyone dies again or when Tom
Holland says writing that Pegasus was
mental damage everyone would just be
like hey yeah okay but now one super
interesting alternate ending has leaked
with a scene description from the
directors revealing who actress
Catherine Lankford played why it was
removed from the film and what this
deleted ending tells us about Marvel's
intentions for future films last year it
was reported that Catherine Lankford
from 13 reasons why would be playing a
role in the ventures in game and we
speculated everything from Hawkeye's
Protege Kate Bishop to Thanos's mommy
Suisse on but also we predicted possibly
an older version of Tony and peppers
daughter which is who Langford in a
plane in this deleted alternate ending
here's what was gonna happen after Tony
Stark's snap in the final battle the one
that wiped out the anis and his forces
Starks consciousness was going to
transport to the orange colored soul
world's realm described by Joe Russo as
a metaphysical weigh station the same
place that Thanos went after his snap an
infinity war where he met his daughter
Gamora
it did it cost
in this ultimate Indian post snap Stark
was in Thanos's place
similarly meeting his daughter Morgan
but an adult version of her played by
Kathryn Langford Morgan was going to
forgive Tony and give him peace to go an
in-game Morgan Stark was the one good
thing to come out of Tony's post defeat
life and the main thing holding him back
from reversing the snap he didn't want
to lose her and he would have felt
guilty about leaving her behind to save
the universe this scene would have aimed
to provide emotional closure to that
inner conflict the Russa said that this
concept felt resonant on the page but
after they shot it it ended up just
being too many ideas and an already over
complicated movie and that when they
showed this scene to test audiences test
audiences found it really confusing
Anthony Russo added that we didn't feel
an emotional association with the adult
version of Morgan this would be a
completely new face and it just wasn't
really resonating with them ultimately
the directors and screenwriters said
that they always intended on endgame
ending with Tony sacrificing himself and
cap to return to Peggy to finally get
that rain check on the dance but without
this adult Morgan Stark seen Tony
Stark's final moments adjusted away from
a spiritual metaphysical aesthetic to a
more personal farewell from Peter Parker
and Pepper Potts whom honestly fans
recognized as having a longer on-screen
history with Tony and really being more
part of his family
pepper told him in the scene it's okay
you can rest a call back to their
earlier scene when pepper told Tony that
he wouldn't be able to sleep unless he
helped the Avengers in their time heist
but the fact that the filmmakers
intended on an adult Morgan start
playing a larger role in Ironman
send-off is worth noting because as I
explained to my other breakdown of the
mysterious hammering audio that played
after the endgame credits this movie
might be hinting at what is coming next
when it comes to how Iron Man's legacy
will live on in the MCU Peter and pepper
at Starks deathbed are important
obviously because both of them are
donning armor designed by stark they're
both capable candidates to carry the
torch of his brilliance no let's be
honest spider-man's obviously a bit more
fun of a successor to follow
nothing gets win of Paltrow I just don't
want to have to start looking for Easter
eggs on the coop homepage but Morgan
Stark is also a possible successor now
endgame introduced her character wearing
an Iron Man helmet and gauntlets and
she's already proved
to be quotable with that adorable line I
love you 3000 which if you think about
it actually reveals her intellect since
it was response to Tony saying I love
you tons with a ton equally 2,000 pounds
a fact that Morgan must know if she
heightens it to 3000 if the Russos cast
an exciting upcoming talent like
Catherine Lankford as an adult Morgan
someone they intended to play a major
role in Tony Stark's departure
it says the reason that Marvel might
have some ideas for a future Catherine
Lankford Morgan Stark alongside figures
like Peter Parker carrying iron man's
legacy into the next generation would
you have preferred this deleted
alternate ending to be included in that
theatrical cut or do you think endgame
worked better without it comment down
below with your thoughts and follow me
on Instagram and Twitter a TA boss
subscribe to new rock stars on YouTube
and follow our new podcast feed inside
marvel for early access to all of our
Marvel coverage thank you for joining me
and imagine what it was like for Mark
Ruffalo to watch Avengers in game the
first time and see the real ending you
mean Hulk doesn't become president I
can't believe they lied to me
[Music]